here's a physician and researcher from
California called dr. Dan Erickson
Erickson and a partner just delivered a
50-minute briefing on the latest numbers
from California the video they made has
been viewed millions of times in a few
days online the bottom line is after
looking carefully at the data these two
researchers have concluded that
California should end its
shelter-in-place order
watch we've seen 1227 deaths in the
state of California with a possible
incidence or prevalence of 4.7 million
that means you have a 0.03 chance of
dying from kovat 19 the state of
California 0.03 chance of dying from
kovat in the state of California is that
does that necessitate sheltering in
place does that necessitate shutting
down medical systems does that
necessitate people being out of work
these are serious people who've done
this for a living for decades they have
in their hands the largest currently
available data sets on this question and
the question they're asking after
analyzing all of those numbers are the
lock downs worth it so what is the
answer to that what's so striking is
that so many politicians the ones
enforcing the lock downs don't seem at
all interested in asking it instead
they're bullying forward as if nothing
has changed just today the San Francisco
Bay Area announced it'll be extending
its lock down until the end of May
that's five weeks from now what is the
scientific justification for doing that
they didn't tell us because there is
none none
you may remember what they first told us
back in February and March they said we
have to take radical steps in order to
quote flatten the curve well six weeks
later we're happy to say that curve has
been flattened but it's likely not
because of the lock downs the virus just
isn't nearly as deadly as we thought it
was all of us including on this show
everybody thought it was but it turned
out not to be hospitals never collapsed
outside of a tiny number of places they
never came close to collapsing at least
not from an influx of infected patients
instead something remarkable happened
something amazing really without
American history the opposite happened
thanks to the lockdowns hospitals have
become to collapse why from a lack of
patients politicians you couldn't pass
9th grade biology decided that
practicing physician should not be
allowed to calculate the risk of
transmitting the virus they're just not
qualified unlike us
so these politicians banned so-called
non-essential procedures many of which
are in fact essential the results of
this policy in many hospitals entire
floors have been mothballed doctors and
nurses are being furloughed in the
middle of a pandemic this is insanity it
weakens our healthcare system its
effects will last for many years that's
all from the lockdown so how long will
we have to live with these lockdowns
earlier this month dr. Anthony Fauci
whom we are apparently required by law
to respect no matter what he says
suggested that in fact we may never be
allowed to resume normal life if back to
normal means acting like there never was
a coronavirus problem I don't think
that's gonna happen until we do have a
situation where you can completely
protect the population if you want to
get to pre corona virus you know that
might not ever happen in the sense of
the fact that the threat is there now we
should tell you that is the same doctor
fact you can keep this to yourself
because as noted it's not allowed to
show any skepticism whatsoever but
that's the same doctor fowey who also
announced that shaking hands the ancient
custom of shaking hands should be done
away with forever and then a week later
told snapchat that actually it's fine to
have sex with strangers you meet on
tinder that was his epidemiological
advice other experts on television
warned that full-blown lock downs may be
necessary until a vaccine or effective
treatments are found what they didn't
mention is that scientists have never
produced a single approved vaccine or
antiviral drug for any coronavirus so
that could be a while and that thought
seemed to please frequent television
guests
immanuel realistically kovat 19 will be
here for the next 18 months or more we
will not be able to return to normalcy
until we find a vaccine or effective
medications is all that economic pain
worth trying to stop kovat 19 the truth
is we have no choice
oh the truth is we have no choice well
here's a handy guide for in case you
watch a lot of television when a
political operative like Zeke Emanuel
someone with a long history of lying
begins a sentence with the phrase the
truth is you should probably be on guard
when he ends that sentence with we have
no choice you should be terrified and in
fact that's wrong we have always had a
choice other countries made different
choices from ours in fact they're not
waiting for a vaccine to open their
societies why would they do that there's
no precedent for doing that as a
scientific matter for example we spent
millions of dollars and more than a
decade trying to find a vaccine for the
SARS virus scientists never developed
one that's a shame but did we halt life
in the United States in response we
didn't in fact you may not even remember
that any of that happened the striking
thing is the science has not changed
that much since then unfortunately
American politics have changed a lot and
that's the difference